you and Magnus played a private game 40
games of Blitz in 2010 in Moscow at a
hotel
this sounds and just feels legendary
final score was 24 and a half to 15 and
a half for Magnus where'd you find out
the score I'm actually curious I don't
think it was publicly set or it was very
briefly said but it wasn't ever like
mentioned in a serious way so I think
it's a deep dive based on a few links
that started as at a subreddit which is
how all great Journeys start
yeah so this is kind of a crazy story
there this was not pre-planned at all I
remember this quite well
um I went out to dinner that final night
with someone who was actually very high
up within the internet chess club at
that time I went out for a nice dinner I
think I had like a couple of drinks
maybe it was wine beer I don't know what
it was and I think towards the end of
the dinner somehow they got word of this
and they they relayed the information to
me that Magus wanted to play a private
match now I agreed to play this match
probably I should not have and actually
has nothing to do with like the state of
having been out had a few drinks
anything of that nature but the reason
that I probably should not have agreed
to play this match and Y very oftentimes
reference it as one of the biggest
mistakes in terms of competitive trust
that I made is specifically because it
gave Magnus a chance to understand my
style of Chess and at the time I
actually had pretty good results against
Magnus I think maybe he was up one or
two games but there were many games
where I'd been pressing close to winning
against him prior to that match and so
when I went and played that match there
were a few things that happened first of
all Magnus really started to understand
my style because we played all sorts of
different openings and so I think he
understood that at times I wasn't so
great in the opening and there were many
openings where I would play slightly
dubious variations as opposed to the
main lines and then secondly from my
standpoint the problem that I realized
since we were playing with an increment
there are many games where I was close
to winning and he would defend end games
amazingly well he would defend what our
technical technically drawn end games
but where I would have like an extra
pawn it would be like rook and Bishop
versus rook and Knight say I have four
pawns he has three pawns end games of
this nature now if you aren't super into
chess you might not understand what I'm
referring to if you are you will but
their end games where one side might
have extra material and extra Pawn say
extra two pawns but theoretically it's a
drawn so can you give an example of the
set of pieces we're talking about five
six seven pieces like so okay like a
very basic one would be rook in four
pawns against rook and three pawns so
that would be nine total pieces on the
board four pawns on one side three pawns
on the other side wide but it's on the
same side of the board now this is a
technical draw it's been known for
probably let's just say 70 years roughly
give or take that this is a theoretical
draw no matter the position of the pawns
it's just all the pawns are on one side
of the board so like but like where they
are so it's like let's just say they're
let's just say they're four pawns right
here they're just four pawns and black
is three pawns so your pawns are on H6
G6 and F6 and there are no other pawns
on the board something like this and you
both have Rooks and it's a draw no
matter what the next next like 50 moves
of the game are we know that it's a
drawn end game
um with perfect play and so it was
things like this where Magnus actually
saved I want to say like five or six of
these and I remember it quite well
because I think the score was very very
close up until probably the last like 10
games of the match and then at the end
he started winning he started winning in
Spades but there are a lot of situations
where he was up like one game or maybe
two games in the match and I had some
end game like this and I was not able to
win the end game and so for me after
that match it wasn't even so much that I
lost the match with a margin I lost by
but it was the fact that I realized how
hard it was to beat him even once you
got the advantage and I think for Magnus
he learned that my weakness was the
openings I remember because I actually I
don't remember the game itself but there
was a game we played in the Sicilian
night or um and he played this variation
with Bishop G5 on move number six I'm
sure you can you can insert a graphic
later I can show you and I think it's a
type of opening sicilian's the opening
night orifice variation it was played by
Bobby Fischer the form world champion
Gary Kasparov as well and so we played
all sorts of different openings because
of course it's not as serious it's it's
a serious match but it's not serious
where it's going to count for the
ranking so you're trying to fill out
where your opponent is strong versus
weak and so there was one game I
remember this very clearly he played the
bishop G5 variation in the night or and
I think I played E5 or I played Knight
bd7 and E5 which is dubious it's not the
best response and that's just one
example where I was playing things that
were a little bit dubious and I was not
playing the absolute main line with 20
moves of theory so I was trying to get
outside of Theory and I think Magnus
learned from that that even though it
appeared that I was very well prepared
in in these openings I wasn't quite at
that level couldn't you have a different
interpretation of you going outside of
the main line that you're willing to
experiment take risks that you're
chaotic and that's actually a strength
not a weakness especially when you're
sitting in a hotel room at late at night
this is past midnight
um playing chess I mean why do you
interpret that that's your weakness
because Magnus going forward was able to
figure out the lines where you have to
be super precise you cannot deviate at
all and I got punished out of the
opening in many games so it was like it
wasn't about the night or if the the
opening or the variation specifically
but he knew what my repertoire was and
we'd pick lines where I had to play the
absolute best lines in order to equalize
um or I would be much worse and he was
very effective at doing that but
nevertheless it's pretty legendary that
the two of you you're one of the best
chess players in the world throughout
the whole period still today
that you just sat down in a hotel room
and played a ton of Chess like what was
that like I mean what's the there's a I
think there's a there is a little here
there is a little video of it sure I
mean this is like epic right how did
this video Exist by the way I think
there was one journalist uh Macaulay
Peterson who's who's able to
um film parts of it so it was it was in
a room it was me Magnus I think Henrik
was there I think Macaulay was there and
that was it people can go on YouTube and
watch it's on chess digital strategies
Macaulay Peterson channel for people
just listening to this there's a a dimly
lit room with the yellow light emerging
out of the darkness of the two faces
I mean and the deep focus here and what
time is this this is must be this is
probably like one in the morning this
was uh I believe the day of day after
the fun this was the day that the final
round occurred and the closing ceremony
so we're playing afterwards I mean are
you able to appreciate the epicness of
this many of my favorite memories are
actually similar to this another memory
that I really have that I recall very
fondly was after the US Championship it
was called the 2005 U.S Chess
Championship was held at the end of 2004
and I believe it's in La Jolla and San
Diego I won that event and after that
that event I was playing Blitz probably
for like four or five hours in the lobby
of the hotel so it's the same kind of
situation where you're just playing for
the Love of the Game as opposed to
anything else of course nowadays
um I think both are Magnus and myself
just playing a dimly lit room like this
would almost certainly not happen there
would probably have to be um certain
Stakes involved for for us to play but
you know if you go back in time these
are the sorts of uh memories and moments
that would happen all the time so is
there a part of you that doesn't regret
that this happened you know I think it
comes back to my general philosophy I
feel like everything happens for a
reason and so because I have that that's
one of my core beliefs like I don't
really look back on it as mistakes I
feel like everything has happened and
things have transpired the way they have
for a reason if I look at in terms of
potentially like World Championship
aspirations I think certainly it was a
big mistake because from a competitive
standpoint Magnus figured out what my
weaknesses were at the time and he
exploited it for many many years